lindsay is with us in phoenix arizona hi
lindsay how are you good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
um well i'm a single mom and
i have 50 000 um
in savings wow but i guess i'm kind of
uh yeah i'm stuck as in
should i use that for a down payment on
a house um because my income isn't that
high
or if i should invest it um i guess i'm
kind of just like spark on
what to do with it what's your income
um this year it should be 52
000 a year um but i've um usually
like the last whatever six years it's
been like 26 or less
so why is it so high now um i moved
and i got a different job good for you
good for you how many kids you got and
what ages
i'm just one and she's six oh good
okay so a single mom making 52
000 a year and in phoenix arizona
and you have fifty thousand dollars in
cash where'd you get fifty thousand in
cash
um i just i saved um a lot like i saved
all my texts
um returned um ever since i had my
daughter
and just i lived at home
for about almost five years
until recently when i moved um so that
helped
and then how old are you just working
really
hard i'm 29. okay
yeah you're that's impressive making 25
000 bucks and you save
50. that's a grind out yeah i thought
i've always been like much of the favor
um but uh my daughter's
father he basically stole a lot of money
from me and ruined my credit score
so after all that i
just really put my mind to it and fate
didn't
got my credit score up girl you're a
warrior that's what i'm talking about
good for you
i'm proud of you well done very well
done well
um what we teach our baby steps and
baby step one is a thousand dollars two
is to be debt free
other than your home you've done those
two three is to have an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
are you debt free yeah i mean just my
car payment
oh well that would be a deal okay
how much do you how much do we owe on
said car
um i think maybe a little less than ten
thousand
i should be done in like a year now
okay so if you were going to follow our
plan and do what we teach
which is obviously what i recommend and
it's how i live and it's how i teach
people to live
you would pay off your car today
and you would take some of the remaining
the remaining forty thousand dollars and
we would set some of it aside as an
emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
i'm gonna call that twenty thousand
dollars
okay and so 30 of your 50 has been
allocated to paying off the car and 20
of it's set aside so that's
that leaves us 20 000 of still asking
the question what do we do with it
you follow what i did
10 on the car i'm sorry 10 on the car 20
in the rainy day fund
leaving us 20 to do something else with
right okay and right now it's just
another regular bank account
it doesn't have to be invested to be
fancy you are way ahead of people who
make 10 times more than you make
they can't save a nickel you're amazing
so now what i would do if i were in your
shoes is i would leave that 20 000 in a
separate bank account
i'm going to name that bank account
house fund
and now that we don't have a car payment
and we're going to live on a budget
and we're going to make twice as much as
you ever made
i'm gonna put money on top of that 20
and money on top of that 20 and money on
top of that 20
and in two or three years i'm going to
buy a house with a really large down
payment and i'm going to use that
down payment money for that account
okay meanwhile you never borrow money
again
when you do buy the house you put it on
a 15-year fixed
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay
but i'm going to guess and say you're
probably going to put down 100 000
on a house
i don't know that's a lot that gives me
like the the thing is
you wanna know how i did that let me
help you i did that okay you saved
fifty you saved fifty thousand making
twenty five
now you make 52.
i think you're gonna save 100 really
fast
i know but i still think you're going to
save really i think really really
you make twice what you used to make
it's just in your nature
you're a warrior and you're a saver and
you just you're incredible
and i want you to do a budget with your
six-year-old daughter i want you to
bring her into this
and let her practice it and this this
is how you're going to start to change
this family we're going to buy us
we're going to buy us a house baby girl
that's exactly right and every week
she's going to get to make the little
chain with you or whatever game you'll
come up with but she's going to learn
how awesome her mom is what an absolute
um great mother and saver and
planner and builder her mom is and she's
going to learn what a strong
invested woman looks like and you're
going to she's going to walk alongside
you it's gonna be
a great journey for both of you it is
interesting to me in a culture that has
completely gone wussified where
everybody spends all their time being a
victim
everybody spends all their time looking
for something to be offended by
i get this sweet little voice on the
phone who is a stronger warrior
than almost anybody out there listening
man
that woman's incredible yes she is and
you you and
and so unassuming you would never think
that conan the barbarian lives in her
soul with a giant sword right
yeah yeah it's just so sweet
man oh
but she looks at that baby girl every
morning and says we're gonna do this
yeah right she's got a big big why 52
percent saying all the moms
live below the poverty level not her
yeah she doubled her income she made a
move
yeah she lived at home for a while moved
out say 50 thousand dollars
listen if you're out there and you had a
tendency to whine
after that call you're done now just
shut up you're oh it's over now
your whining is over now